next question cool thanks okay and this
is from IG lp3 hey there
here's my question oh my name is Chloe
via real hi Chloe
how do you stay the course in spite of
the inner negative narrative so many
writers deal with that says everything
you make sucks that's a good question
oh it's rich it's really rich oh man
goddess Chloe oh man Wow
yeah gosh I feel like I didn't speak on
this for days um I would say like in
particular like how do I get to dark
here but uh but I think writing is
inherently like the only person you're
battling is yourself really most of the
time because and I think in particular
at least for me I can only speak to my
experience but I I struggle a lot with
like self-hatred like I there's lots of
parts of myself that I hate and I'm only
sort of just now getting over a lot of
these types of things but like when it's
just you and a blank screen and a cursor
flashing sometimes like all of your
insecurities and things just bubble up
and it gets in the way of you of you
getting your creative thoughts onto the
page and I've learned just for me like
when I'm able to give myself permission
to write the worst most terrible pages
of all time then I can do it and then I
know in my like in my back pocket I know
that writing is a process so I know that
like whatever I try on my first attempt
is probably not gonna be very good in
fact like you know the the terrible
first draft is like that's just kind of
a law in how I see it
there are other people who I'm sure are
brilliant that can pump out a genius
first draft I am NOT that person I will
never be that person and so for me when
I'm allowed to give myself grace and
allow myself to write terribly
you just write things that don't make
sense to write sentence fragments to
write and then they fight I'll come back
later
and then keep going you know what I mean
like when I allow myself that sort of
level of freedom then I can write and I
feel like on paper I shouldn't be a
writer because I'm like myself criticism
in my brain is pretty fierce and
sometimes it's unbearable but I think
that you you do you have to give
yourself grace and you have to like
again I don't want to be too new agey
but you got to like kind of love
yourself you know what I mean you have
to be okay with yep these are some
terrible words but you know their words
and that's all that matters right now in
this particular instance the only thing
that matters is like I'm putting words
onto the page they don't have to be the
right words and I want to be in the
right order but their words and for at
least for our first draft that's the
that's the thing that I think when I
learn that sort of like you know
unlocked in my brain I'm just like oh
this draft doesn't count
it doesn't count because I'm gonna I can
go back and fix it later and so writing
with a reckless abandon of like this
doesn't have to be good this is supposed
to be bad anyone can write a terrible
thing you know I mean terrible just in
terms of the mechanics of the words like
anybody can write something terrible you
know and like that's how I find my entry
into it it's like if all right I know
for a fact that I can write something
terrible if my goal is to sit down and
be a genius I can't hit that every day
but I can hit being really bad every day
and so that's my only metric of success
is like are there words on the page yes
I don't my metric of success is not are
they good words is this good that's for
that's for later sure if I've mentioned
this before but there's this thing
called the dunning-kruger effect and I'm
probably butchering the name of it but I
think it's something to the effect of
those who think that they're really
horrible at something are actually
better than maybe most people I'm not
sure I'm put
during this concept but then those who
actually think like I'm really good at
this they're actually mistaken and it's
this weird like duality that they're
there so people that are actually more I
don't know if the word is like self
effacing but they actually are better
than what they they think they're doing
and then the opposite is true
I don't know that's just yeah something
that yeah I think that kind of makes
sense I think there's I think there
might be something to that because you
know I think that you have to be
relatively self-aware I think and well I
I guess you don't have to be but I think
self-awareness as a writer is a good
thing because you essentially and and
you know but self-awareness gone
unchecked can be unproductive but if you
can like find a mechanism or a way to
where you can use that as a tool as a
way to like be able to look at something
critically but look at it later
critically that's a really good skill to
have
because it allows you to empathize with
people which is really all that we're
trying to do in our stories is like
create empathy between the audience and
the characters that's all we're trying
to do and so that's a I think that
people that might think like I'm
terrible at this I know I'm in that
crowd like I think that can be a
strength when used like a tool you know
used in a very calculated way of like
okay I wrote this thing it's really bad
how can i I know it's bad how can I make
it good how can I do that and that sort
of like not assuming that you have all
the answers to things I think can open
your you up to making much better work
in a long-term immersive you like the
two characters in adaptation
yeah so you know you see the one he's
the one that feels
and and you know like there's there's so
much but it's just a matter what he
feels about him yeah is like it's like
just pumping it out yeah it's like I
think I sold this already nice car you
know all these things and it is like it
doesn't make sense but you see that
sometimes in life and we wonder how is
that possible well I think it's
sometimes it's just all of someone's
perception of themselves and it's
absolutely this weird thing yeah yeah
like what you what you think kind of is
your reality you know like if you think
that you're terrible like you're
probably not gonna pump out you're
probably not even gonna get the words
out you know and so like yeah when I
write when I at least for me because I
feel like in in theory I shouldn't be a
writer because I struggle too much with
self-hatred
but I learned yeah I learned that like
if you just give yourself permission to
be terrible
you can do it because everybody can be
really bad at something sure you know
it's like you know I think there's a
there's a John Lennon quote or he's like
I'm a musician if you hand me a tuba
I'll get something out of it you know
and like I I get that now it's just like
oh you he didn't say it would be good
all he said was like I can get something
out of this you know and I think if we
create from that perspective especially
on like first drafts and first attempts
of things you really can't go wrong
because you can anybody can probably get
something out of a tuba yeah my hurts
your ears but right exactly it could
shatter all the glass in the room but
that's okay
you